gas relation is the process of formation
of three germ layers from the AP blast
of the blastocyst
these are ectoindu and mesoderm all
these events happen in the week 3 of
embryonic development and it all starts
from the bilaminar embryonic disc AP
blast is the future embryo actually
and hypoblast develop into other
structures
gastrulation is all about coordinated
cell movement which give rise to all
these three layers
initially A Primitive streak forms in
the mid-sagittal plane and cellular
movement happens across this primitive
streak cells move inwards downwards and
then outwards and form different layers
like the definitive endodrum at the
beginning
then the intermediate mesoderm and
eventually the ectoderm by day 17 all
the layer formation is done eventually
organogenesis would generate different
organs from these layers